what's going on reject nation I'm the
Greg album Instagram and Twitter
oh and I mad at John Humphrey on
Instagram and Twitter and we have a real
reject Instagram someone took the real
rejects apparently yes this is some guy
isn't considering hitting on being like
hey but for right now at least we're
real Regis yeah we might change it it's
that time again with Roger Arrakis
sketch blue house of rakha I'm excited
been a while since I've seen one of the
houses how to get super cars over last
videos of law and they got a mansion the
cool mention is look at huge did they
destroy it they did expect nothing less
and before we go into this video I want
to give a heads up gonna be doing shout
out for Jeff bearskin Peterson bearskin
the day shout out so keep a lookout for
that Jeff Tod
[Music]
[Music]
good morning house director it's day 2
in the racket house things are going
well but the boys are off for a shoot in
Sydney today 6 a.m. I'll [ __ ] me now
your stress be downstairs
Michael literally has never [ __ ]
little tiny boys if you need legal 6:30
what will start on your shower 6:30 all
right
yeah well credi [ __ ] you don't mind
Masaki like isn't it fun oh my gosh oh
[ __ ] whoa whoa
here's bloody mess Wow never once
potheads really pour you out that my
head on down tonight everyone on set
it's like no Christian he's not a
[ __ ] person you don't happen
that's a flute shrieking some sheet up
here that's about the gold bang
eventually yes whoa
when evil comes that was my start 90s
Danny's too big one
we prefer to go hungry Christian yeah
hahaha forward John baby's insane
[ __ ] cell phone
right down [ __ ]
oh yeah behind this yeah Shawn find out
how to water shock on how do you own a
job now a shot gotta be 40 cop looking
for G big shot I don't know Melissa you
anymore boy knowing from your ass well I
don't know which cheek it might we ask
the scripts on his shoulders ha ha ha ha
any last words or buydig
ah those little things sir for something
like this that's the best exposure
McDonough as this is the only thing
[Music]
if you ever saw the movie hacks or
recipes the God within hacks or rich
okay that was one bubble now we're going
to do two dananana Gannon Wow yeah if we
read in the comments about the few small
nuts you guys were wondering why it did
happen last episode the physical type
will didn't come in until last night so
it's heated now and be muscles going to
be bursting today all stop
the real estate agent comes over gets on
his way to describe checking in no
coming in a big Hey oh yes the most of
you with it stop for anything
waiting questions you're not wrong
there's a door upstairs time now
latitude you want to take down pretty
problems because it's left you know the
key fort is our key that we can put into
it or how do we like that scenario sonic
that could be right you just want your
partner on evolutive the controls will
take the package a little bit doubtful I
make comma exactly
[Music]
[Music]
you're going to work experiment shutter
your own structures fired up when she
[ __ ] dude
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] he won't do rid of him
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what is that under Danny
that's maybe Michael two topics ladies a
chance for the 2017 football
championship to the winner kaesong a mr.
bedroom
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
No
Oh down insomnia slow for my name is
blue is the harmony don't hardly knew
before mama sweet show swallow me whole
I got to show you that video
Oh ass video man oh boy yeah
you